- Hello Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all the major problems of the world.
I started the Mentor Me
series on this channel
with the goal to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully by watching
more of their content
some of their thoughts, their mindsets
their beliefs, their attitudes
their way of thinking seeps into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Maya Angelou
and some of her most inspiring moments.
Mentor me Maya.
Moment number four is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as Maya is talking
if she says something
that really inspires you
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well
and when you write it down yourself
it's much more likely to stick
so you remember it too.
Enjoy.
(inspiring music)
- I've tried a lot of things.
I've failed at some things
and succeeded at some.
- Yeah but what I love about you
is that you have, you have attacked it all
with great passion.
I mean, look at all the books here
that you have written.
I can look at all the things you have done
from journalist to
poet, to writer to actor
to producer, all of those kinds of things.
Which suggest this uncommon
confidence in yourself
and willingness to risk failure.
- Yes.
But maybe it's more
dangerous to risk success.
- [Charlie] What do you mean?
- Well a lot of people
don't really want success.
- [Charlie] I've never understood that.
- This is true.
- And maybe because they don't want it
and the best evidence of
that is that they fail.
And the best evidence of that
is they don't try things.
- That's right.
- [Charlie] Right.
But to succeed means that I mean
you're in front of God
and lots of responsible people
and you have to either eat your words
or stand by them.
I think that I agreed a
long time ago Charlie Rose
this may be what my greatest blessing.
I agreed a long time ago that I would die.
Now, whew.
If I can admit that.
That no matter what happens,
I will do this thing.
This is the biggest bugaboo of them all.
I will do that.
Well then why couldn't I
attempt something lesser?
- [Charlie] Yeah.
- So I will try.
- Well what the '60s
must have been like for anybody.
Was it eight or nine assassinations.
What does that do to a generation?
Having lived through it and
having known these people.
This is me.
I imagine I'd still be angry.
I'd be angry with my country,
I'd be angry at anybody
who let that happen to my friends.
- No.
If you're not angry
you're either a stone
or you're too sick to be angry.
You should be angry.
- [Dave] But what do you do?
- You never mind it,
that's the difference.
You must not be bitter.
- [Dave] Oh that's all?
(laughs)
- Let me show you why.
Bitterness is like a cancer.
It eats upon the host.
It doesn't do anything to the object
of its displeasure.
So you said anger, yes.
You write it, you paint it, you dance it
you march it, you vote it.
You do everything about it, you talk it.
Never stop talking it.
When I was seven and a half
I was raped.
I won't say severely
raped, all rape is severe.
The rapist
was a person very well known to my family.
I was hospitalized.
The rapist was let out of jail
and was found dead that night
and the police suggested
that the rapist had been kicked to death.
I was seven and a half.
I thought that I had caused
the man's death
because I had spoken his name.
That was my seven and
a half year old logic.
So I stopped talking for five years.
Now, to show you again
how out of evil there can come good.
In those five years, I read every book
in the Black School Library.
I read all the books I could get
from the White School Library.
I memorized James Weldon Johnson
Paul Larnstom, Countee
Cullen and Langston Hughes.
I memorized Shakespeare, whole plays.
50 sonnets.
I memorized Edgar Allen Poe.
All the poetry.
Never having heard it, I memorized it.
I had Longfellow, I had Guy de Maupassant.
I had Balzac.
(sighs)
Rudyard Kipling.
I mean, it was Catholic kind of reading.
And Catholic kind of storing.
When I decided to speak
I had a lot to say
and many ways in which
to say what I had to say.
I listened to the black minister
and listened to the
melody of the preachers
and I could tell when they would start up
on that kind of thing
whether you know they
mean to take our souls
straight to heaven
or whether they meant to
dash us straight to hell.
I understood it.
So out of this evil
which was a dire kind of evil
because rape on the body of a young person
more often than not
introduces cynicism.
And there's nothing quite so tragic
as a young cynic.
Because it means the person
has gone from knowing nothing
to believing nothing.
In my case, I was saved
in that muteness you see?
And the soledad, I was saved.
And I was able to draw from human thought
human disappointments and triumphs
enough to triumph myself.
- I see you as a brave-heart woman.
(laughs)
How do you see yourself Dr. Angelou?
- A working woman.
I work hard.
- [Interviewer] Yes.
You say, "Always in the process
"And never take your shoes off."
- That's it.
And working all the time.
I laugh as much as possible.
- Yeah.
- I just don't trust
people who don't laugh.
Who act as if, "I'm serious."
Who act as if they've got
some kind of airplane glue
and stuck their fist to their forehead.
I think I don't know if
you're serious or not.
You're boring as the dickens
but that's for being serious.
I think if you're serious
you're trying to make a change.
If you don't like a situation,
you try to change it.
Do whatever you can to change it.
And if everything you do falls flat
and you can't change it
then change the way you think about it.
Move to another position to look at it.
In doing so, you may find
a new way to change it.
People will very often
try to respond to you
on the level on which you address them.
So if you say, "Aren't you wonderful?
"Aren't you splendid?
"My goodness you're beautiful.
"Oh, you're so bright."
People will try, even if they're not
they really will try to
lift themselves up to that.
On the other hand, if you say
"You know you're a dog.
"You really are so low.
"You'll never be anybody.
"In fact, you're a nobody now
"And you never have been."
Sooner or later, that person will address.
Will respond on the level
on which he or she is addressed.
He will say figuratively or literally
"Let me show you where dog is.
"Let me show you where low really is.
"I will show you that."
Years ago I did a movie
called Poetic Justice
and there was a young man the first day
who cursed so, I couldn't believe it.
I walked around and behind him.
Tried to ignore him.
But the second day, he and
another young man, black man
ran to each other and
they were about to fight
and hundreds of extras
started to run away.
But one black man walked
up to the two young men
and I walked up
and I took one by his shoulder.
I said, "Let me speak to you."
He said, "If these men
would do, would do."
I said, "Let me speak to you honey."
"Well I'll tell you something."
(grumbles)
I said, "No let me talk to you please."
And he finally calmed down.
And I said, "Do you know
how much you are needed?
"Do you know what you mean to us?
"Do you know that hundreds
of years of struggle
"Have been for you, you?
"Please baby, take a minute.
"Don't lose your life on a zoon."
I put my arm around him.
He started to weep.
The tears came down,
that was Tupac Shakur.
I took him, I walked him
down into a little deli
and kept his back to the people
so that they wouldn't see him.
And I used my hands to dry his cheeks.
And I kept talking to
him sweetly, sweetly.
For the next week while I was on that film
whenever I'd walk by he would be saying
"So I told him!"
He said, "Good morning Miss Angelou."
(laughs)
Dears, try to introduce courtesy
into your speech to each other.
You have no idea what it would do
for your brother or sister
to whom you speak.
And you surely have no idea
what it would do for you.
It will lift you up.
At Martin King's request
I rejoined the Southern
Christian Leadership Conference
because I had left him to go to Malcolm.
- Was it really separated,
the movements like that?
- Oh my goodness.
The Malcolm was in the
states it was so separated.
Malcolm even made Martin look like a Tom.
Until he understood what was happening.
But that's the wonderful
thing about the icon.
You continue to grow.
And you develop courage.
The most important of all the virtues.
Because without courage,
you can't practice
any other virtue consistently.
If you've seen another truth
and had enough courage to
change your way of thinking.
To say hey everybody, you know
what I said in that street?
I don't believe that anymore.
A little challenge will straighten me out.
What I love about my life.
There's nothing I don't
love about my life.
It's a struggle, but that's life.
That's why they call it life.
When I think cruelty, that's unfair.
That's nasty.
Cruelty to anyone, that's rude and stupid.
But I don't see a lot of that
and if I do, I try to
do something about it
rather than I don't just
sit in the dark and curse the dark.
I try to light a match.
You may write me down in history
with your bitter, twisted lies.
You may trod me in the very dirt
but still like dust, I'll rise.
Does my sassiness upset you?
Why are you beset with gloom?
Just because I walk as if I have oil wells
pumping in my living room.
(audience laughs)
Just like moons and like suns
with the certainty of tides.
Just like hope springing high.
Still I rise.
Did you want to see me broken?
Bowed head and lowered eyes.
Shoulders falling down like tear drops.
Weakened by my soulful cries.
Does my sassiness upset you?
(laughs)
Don't take it so hard just because I laugh
as if I have gold mines
digging in my own backyard.
You can shoot me with your words.
You can cut me with your lies.
You can kill me with your hatefulness
but just like life, I'll rise.
Does my sexiness offend you, aw.
(audience laughs)
Does it come as a surprise
that I dance
as if I have diamonds at
the meeting of my thighs.
(audience laughs)
Out of the huts of history, shame I rise.
Up from a past rooted in pain, I rise.
A black ocean leaping and wide
welling and swelling
and baring in the tide.
Leaving behind nights of terror
and fear, I rise.
Into a daybreak
miraculously clear, I rise.
Bringing the gifts that my ancestors gave
I am the hope and the dream
of the slave and so.
(claps)
Wow!
There I go.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video?
What was the most inspiring
moment from this video
that left its mark on you and why.
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout-out to Lauren.
Lauren, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word
and making that review on
your Youtube channel about it.
I really, really, really appreciate it
and I hope that you enjoyed the read.
- This week I read Your One
Word by Evan Carmichael.
And I've been a fan of
Evan Carmichael's channel
here on Youtube for a while.
He inspires entrepreneurs to go out
and just do their best.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.